Shopping is usually something that women enjoy,...
...but in Dubai, part of the United Arab Emirates,...
...things are different.
Children and men would also be enticed by shopping malls where fantasy is running wild.
Prices are actually no cheaper than anywhere else,...
...but what is captivating about shopping in Dubai...
...is that you feel as if you are in an amusement park.
For example, the Madinat Jumeirah has a waterway...
...that transports people from its shops, bars and restaurants to the nearby hotels.
The massive Mall of the Emirates has an indoor ski slope with real snow.
Isn't this amazing?
But this is not all.
"Dubai Shopping Festival" is held in the first quarter of each year,...
...and there are huge discounts on merchandise.
If you are hungry after shopping, you can either experience five-star cuisine...
...at the Grosvenor and Hilton or go to Al Dhiyafah Road,...
...where there are cheap restaurants like the Ravi Restaurant.